i talked to anthony mackie like last
weekend
and we were talking about working with
you and he said i took a full
punch to the head from gsp
and didn't get knocked out true story he
was very very proud of that
if we get to the border he's not going
to follow
what's up anthony is amazing
i'm going to tell you anthony's i mean
he's an amazing actor and he's someone
who's very charismatic he makes everyone
laugh on the set one day we spent a lot
of hours on the on the choreograph and
there's a scene that
we punched and he duck under and and i
wasn't
able to pull the punch on time and with
with his equipment he had to duck under
so he get
my arm touch his head and i i kind of
clip him on on the elbow
but he's a hell of a tough guy let me
tell you that he stood up right away and
he was okay and i told him
you're probably the only human being
that i ever hit that i think i got
more hurt than you
when it comes to the combat scenes hand
to hand
how much of like your knowledge do they
ask for your input
fighting for real and fighting for a
camera it's two different things
when you do fight for the camera
everything is bigger you need to
telegraph to make it
to make it look better and uh
i got a lot to learn in that department
and disney marvels they always work with
the best
the elite of the elite in that
department and these guys they're really
they're real they're real superheroes
all these stunt guys they were amazing
they do stuff that you might think
sometimes that it's a special effect but
they really do it
like it's unbelievable i was blown away
to see how good they were
there's been a lot of talk about within
the storyline of the falcon and the
winter soldier because of the comics you
know sam does take up the shield and
eventually becomes
captain america do you think anthony
mackie would
be a great captain america he could be
he could be we'll see what the future is
old for him
but one thing for sure is that bachrach
will be ready for him next time and
he's not gonna get that lucky i love
that every time we talk about it you're
still gonna run promo
i love that you're so gonna be like oh
yeah i'm ready for you hey
i never trash talk in my life and mixed
martial art please let me trash talk a
little bit
in acting
you